es el primer gran incendio forestal de
este año en España y acabar con él no
está siendo una tarea fácil aún no se
sabe el origen del fuego que comenzó el
jueves pero sí que los más de 500
bomberos desplegados con 20 aviones y
helicópteros no han podido extinguirlo y
ya calcinado cerca de 4.000 hectáreas en
las provincias de Castellón y Aragón hay
sitios complicados
hoy con el cambio de viento tienen zonas
que se les puede complicar la cosa
y de hecho en la parte del Castellón ahí
lo tienen un poco más
O sea más que lo nuestro el
incendio ya ha obligado a la evacuación
de 1500 vecinos de las localidades
afectadas mientras en las autoridades
intentan controlar las llamas e
investigar sus causas cuya principal
hipótesis es que pudo originarse con una
chispa de una máquina ahora los
ciudadanos de los pueblos afectados sólo
pueden hacer una cosa esperar nos
quedamos con lo puesto ha sido un poco
duro pues asumir que no teníamos ni
cepillos de dientes ni ropa para
cambiarte y estas cosas y que Son
imprescindibles y cotidianas
lo dejen volverá al pueblo Y es que el
sur de Europa está viviendo un invierno
especialmente seco y más caluroso de lo
habitual y se espera una primavera con
las mismas características que aumentará
el riesgo de más incendios como este